[Musique]
yoann perrin selon nos valeurs de
l'élite a travaillé aussi en entreprise
rejoint ses coéquipiers à l'entraînement
j - avant la rencontre face à toulouse
l'une des principales consignes
travailler sans se blesser et encore le
saran loiret handball tout juste promue
au plus haut niveau est la bonne
surprise du début de saison comme des
précédentes d'ailleurs les montées
s'enchaînent de national en lidl stars
league johan a tout vécu
il a débuté ici à 17 ans il va en avoir
34 j'étais pas très doué quand j'étais
jeune j'ai pas de chez nous et
maintenant mais j'étais vraiment loin
d'arriver à jouer dans l'idéal donc
c'est un peu les bisounours comme je
suis là je profite de la chose de voir
des personnes ou des personnages même
pour moi qui j'aurais pas pu jouer un
jour contre es hadrons plaisir c'était
une belle aventure humaine pour tout un
club qui est su garder ses valeurs
partagent et échangent plusieurs pots
enseigne le rendre plus jeune alexis
poirier quitte prématurément
l'entraînement
en quelques minutes le joueur se
transforme en entraîneur ils sont plus à
l'écouté envie d'un jour peut-être
peut-être nous remplacer donc oui
forcément
son j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de passionnés
dans l'équipe à
je vais toujours la même oui ça
m'intéresse pas louise fait tout bien
voir bien voir le regard
je sais que tu sais faire le rendement
et les autres qui commencent à savoir
que tu fais toujours un endroit non bah
oui donc et c'est autre chose il c'est
bien parce que ça tire vers le haut
c'est encourageant de savoir que l'on
peut être entraîné par des parts des
grands joueurs et alors oui il est cool
ça c'est sûr c'est pas mal ça il nous
connaît donc hissé l'exercice qu'il faut
faire dans cause d'exercice en général
qui nous font travailler travailler bien
et progresser les moins de 14 ans alexis
poirier s'illustre régulièrement sur le
terrain premiers supporters évidemment
les mamans certaines ont découvert le
land avec leurs enfants tout s'y
intéresse maintenant et ce sont ici
presque comme à la maison
ce lien avec les coaches qui entraîne
les enfants et puis qui sont qui sont
disponibles sont toujours sympas et
sacré cet add-on envie de venir les voir
est vraiment de connaître même ce même
les joueurs qu'on connaît pas qu'on voit
pas souvent on a l'impression de les
connaître en fait et c'est vraiment un
ensemble on a vraiment l'impression de
faire partie d'une grande famille en
fait et je trouve que ça change par
rapport à certains autres comme entre
guillemets ponder vraiment
distance en fait échange de bons
procédés les pros sont proches des
jeunes et de leurs familles bénévoles
pour certains supporters pour tous
il date
[Applaudissements]